I have something that we that I found
out and
yay that I have to share with you merch
and I'm very this is this is a fun thing
but um I um well we um here's the thing
uh Mark Harley
mm-hmm
hello hello Mark Carly did an AMA hello
Mark I'm ready now some messages and
some things yeah but here's the thing
with the AMA he did I haven't read it
virtue when I'll show it to me he wanted
a way to the show started he mentions us
oh boy yeah so
um flatteringly I'm assuming for those
who don't know and before we get to the
AMA just just let me let me run like a
quick you know just a quick
kind of update uh this was him on
another podcast I don't know what
podcast it was but this is too lazy to
try Clippers by the way just stick to
Bobby she uh you know or Joe just came
to the conclusion that they were out of
line I think it could be a little bit of
both I think Joe just likes to avoid
drama as much as possible like he wants
nothing to do with this unfortunately I
mean I'd love to see Brennan Schaub and
Annie Letterman or kalila on The Joe
Rogan Experience together so also Mark
he starts going off on kalila right here
and he starts imitating her and it's
actually pretty funny very sadistic to
Bobby she uh you can find compilations
of her attempting to humiliate him I
actually noticed it I've seen him yeah
yeah with us commentating over them I
know all of you have we own that
algorithm when they came out on the H3
podcast that was really I'm sitting
there watching it going look at the way
that she emotionally
steam rolls over Bobby he's saying I'm
uncomfortable doing something please
stop doing this are you taking our
talking points and using them as your
own on this show yes those were our
talking points am I incorrect this is
basically what we said yes okay cool
yeah sounds great same old [__] don't be
a Bobby and I'm like that's classic
abusive manipulative Behavior she's
remorseless I don't think she
empathizes with people in a traditional
way I think she has enough emotional
intelligence to like pretend and and pay
lip service to but that's yeah that's
called a sociopath or a psychopath
depending on something you're a woman
should go in therapy we were talking
about how we have to respond am I shut
the [__] up like an impression it's not
bad hey hear me out and I I don't know
if I should do this before we hear the
AMA but let's hear the AMA first okay so
it's kind of the background a little bit
he's been going on going to different
shows and talking about it he was on Red
Bar uh too and he brought some stuff up
um after the red bar thing he went on
Twitter and he like just dropped deep
Brennan DMS and then he did an AMA over
the weekend dropped a voice message to
drop the voice message that's correct
um well Virgie
what's this AMA with hello Mark Carly so
he dropped a few little fun hints uh I
have to I have to go to the Adderall one
after this I have we I have to but oh
that's his merch
yeah so here's the collateral one oh
okay here's here's the question
how do you feel about the way you're
betrayed here or he broke betrayed but
he meant portrait anyways yeah the way
you're portrayed here lots of guys like
to [__] on your looks personality the
way you carry yourself and the things
you say does that have an effect on you
uh and he he made three bullet points
okay bullet point one
bullet point one when men [__] on my
looks it kind of goes in one ear and out
the other because I'm aware of how I
look and I don't have any delusions
about how hot or ugly I am some women
parentheses and men find me attractive
I'm sure many others don't that's fine
blah blah blah here's the good one two
the way I carry myself I also feel like
a lot of my online Persona has been
misinterpreted or been deliberately
interpreted in the least charitable way
possible
I know revenge of the CIS isn't this
subreddit but maybe there's some overlap
but someone sent me this segment where
they're ripping on an hws clip that's
how he uh that's that's what she'll say
oh okay cool
branding I like it yeah
go ahead
Virgie sorry the kid was yelling out
okay uh
I'm being obviously ironic with my faux
narcissism like maybe talking about
being one of the world's most successful
plus-sizers
stop for a second versus doing a
character so everything was a bit
okay so what was your character idiot
like I'm just trying to understand Mark
I'm trying to hear you out here man but
you're not helping yourself you're kind
of proving our point but I just play an
arrogant douchebag on the internet like
it's a character so does Mark you'll get
along oh God
um
Fergie
virtue oh I'm sorry dude the thing was
my bad and they're [__] on me as if
I'm being literal but I get it I invite
the scrutiny my issue with how I carry
myself is I can be [__] awkward I'm
basically a muscular nerd who's
developed some good in-person socialism
he's doing he's I hate him first off you
haven't developed anything you're doing
the thing you're literally [__] about
and now you're doing
hear me out
let's do this I think this is fair
and I'm of course this has to be
unanimous if you say no we don't have to
but hear me out
should we
invite
hello Mark Harley to come on the show
yeah though we're trying to get him on
the show well Mark well now but now
let's now let's see now we know he
watches let's do the official invitation
okay Mark
yes we goof on you obviously okay I
understand and we'll agree that it's
probably hell to work for Brendan shop
that's something that I'll think even
Mercer I will probably go like I don't
care who you are I don't care how much
you goof on you that job has to [__] it
suck we agree with that okay
come on let's have a mark Harley
Redemption Arc
open invite We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna [__] We're Not Gonna Ambush you
I don't know how we would Ambush yeah
we've already said all the worst things
so
you're welcome to come on you're welcome
to tell us and tell us what cycle you're
on uh go ahead
okay uh where was I oh next line yeah I
am not cool and anytime you see me
acting cool it's a [__]
tongue-in-cheek joke First Trust Me Mark
we could tell when you're acting I've
seen your shorts
all right and three which goes basically
I don't even know why he divided it it's
literally the same [__] line of logic
it's [__]
people mostly criticize me in a general
way about what I say I see people say
I'm like a bloviating
pseudo-intellectual narcissist
narcissist word salad machine that's us
that's what we said we say that about
you oh cool I I was looking for the clip
because I've literally heard merch say
that exactly
that's funny oh [__] but it doesn't land
because I know that I communicate and
communicate quite clearly it lands
you're spiraling on Reddit it landed
hold on it was more than a glancing blow
let me let me read this all together
when a fighter gets hit in the face he's
bleeding from the ears and he's lying to
the ref and being like
didn't even hurt you're talking to the
corner post
I love when you see those fights when
they stop them and then the guy's like
eyeballs hanging out eyeballs like no no
no we're stopping this and I think we
all agree that look listen Mark we like
busting your balls obviously you may
well your atrophied balls you make it
easy and he they are he's not enough he
is not enough he he knows that he's
going to be on trt the rest of his life
and that's fine
so is Rogan probably but
I will I will say this
yes
do I out of the two people obviously
Brennan is the worst human being I think
do you agree with me on that Brendan's
the worst human being here okay actually
khalila is worse than you too as a
matter of fact Mark if we're making a
list of people Delilah crystalia Brendan
and you're like waiting on there you're
not yeah you're not even top 10 honest
with you like am I like my opinion
that's the truth you're just a big idiot
Brendan and like kalila and [__] they're
they're bad [__] people you know what
I mean you're just a dummy yeah Mark is
just a silly man you're just an idiot
that like buys Black Market [__]
steroids on the internet and to quote
Ronnie B
don't make it bad person don't make a
bad person but um but steroid we got any
more illegal steroids back there fresh
out oh [__]
um turns out he's got illegal other
things too oh yeah we're gonna get to
that we got some more in this AMA that's
pretty fun
um is that is is there more for that
this this yeah there is okay go ahead
uh I I know that I communicate quite
clearly it never pose as an expert when
I'm not
I am a curious novice in many Realms
true expert and virtually no they say
curiosity killed the gay lion
yeah
however I've recently gotten over my
self-consciousness about dispensing
certain kinds of advice online like in
Fitness because I see it here hold on
let me just skip ahead and read for you
so I challenge anyone if you think I'm a
pseudo-intellectual yes roll the tape
and let's discuss sure
if I'm a narcissist roll the tape and
let's discuss correct
if I'm a fake expert roll the tape and
let's discuss
if I'm a self-absorbed civil solapis
sure you're right if I'm a little
self-destructive in service of providing
entertainment sure you're right if I
have many flaws big and small things to
work on as I grow as a human from time
management to pronouncing certain words
better sure you're right but do I have a
cluster B personality disorder
[Music]
wow so you're just like quoting man you
like memorize our videos that's pretty
flat but it doesn't FaZe man he's not
phased look Mark just come on the show
man it doesn't bother him just come on
the show let's settle this let's you
come on the show we'll talk and maybe at
the end of the day we'll have a big gay
Redemption Arc what do you think I like
it big gay Redemption Online big gay
Redemption big gay Redemption all right
what do you think huh
uh okay so about now this the other
stuff that I want to get into has more
to do with him dishing on Brendan than
less to do with him I think that stuff
was basically him addressing us yeah
um
there's a couple other good fun ones
okay yeah please go ahead go ahead
here's here's one for you Marsh on the
most recent fight companion Brendan said
that he was doing 90 to 120 milligrams
of Adderall per day
yeah you know like info about that yeah
you know like death by a Thousand Cuts
did you see that clip
did you see that clip death by a
thousand okay check this out Brendan uh
sub I I some comedian they might have
been destefina one of the comedians made
fun of Brandon like you know [__] me you
know making fun of him but he was
talking about yeah you know when I watch
The Gringo poppy special it was like
death by a Thousand Cuts is what he said
so then on the fight companion Brian
Callan and Brendan are there and so's
Rogan and then callan's talking and he
goes yeah yeah you know like death by a
Thousand Cuts and he looks at Brennan
huh and Brandon goes [__] you bro wow
all my life Patrick sent it to me that
was whoever yesterday he showed it to me
I was like [__] yeah
uh so go ahead
all right uh 120 milligrams Adderall per
day do you have any info about that and
also do you realize how insane that is
this is three to four times the absolute
maximum a doctor would prescribe anyone
at that point he is causing irreversible
blah blah blah blah blah blah
Mark Carly's answered Mark Harley's
answer Marsh
yes who do you think got it for him he
got he gets Baba his Adderall how much
was he taking
90 to 100 milligrams of Adderall a day
that's not good
also and he owes him money for it this
is the other part also hey [__] face you
stiffed me 450 on the last 30 I got you
so he's he owes him a debt he put a cat
I think he that one he put a cash app
out and he just let it expire why are
you yeah I admitting to crimes though
even throw him on
well he already went on the air and said
he gets and he gets [__] steroids
from the dark web you know no I mean I
get that right but there's a difference
between yeah okay maybe I got some stuff
for myself to now you're admitting to
selling drugs illegally I'd be like yes
a control substance yeah you're right
complain he also said that he just got
off Adderall I had a problem do you
think he stopped taking it because it
was a problem or because he just lost
his plug Mark I mean he only paid me for
the last order when he'd run out so he'd
lay my old cash app then demand more why
is he paying you for Adderall you go to
a doctor he'll Brandon's gonna get this
[__] easy to get out of all now
legally you could do it online with a
Skype call like it's not all it is
that's how I got what I have a doctor he
barely checks him once in a while he
checks in and be like all right yeah but
and they just later on and later on in
the same thread
later on in the same thread
450 for 30 30 milligrams is a good deal
can you help me can you be my new blog
Papa Mark replies I actually offered to
teach people how to use the dark web
because it's annoying to constantly be
getting people [__] when I don't want to
profit off it
first off let me explain some Mark first
smart guy you go about things a real
weird way first off you don't need to go
to the dark web to get Adderall you go
to the regular web to get Adderall all
right let's start that I'm not gonna get
too into specific details but it ain't
that difficult it's pretty [__] easy
and if you don't mind tasting bitter
research chemicals you get it legally
here too so let's calm down but also
don't be teaching people how to use the
[__] dark web you [__] [__] I
would vary get off the [__] dark web
he's got to be careful with that
Adderall [__] though because that's true
honestly you should the ice cream thing
isn't true you shouldn't ever you really
should never be taking 40 more than 40 a
day 60 a day maybe if you've really got
an issue
um like I take
half of a 20 twice a day so I take 20
milligrams a day over the course of a
whole day a hundred and like I'm almost
curious like if I wasn't old and fat and
out of shape and worried about my heart
I'd almost want to try that just to see
how much I'd get done but I think I
would just be in a [__] psychosis
yeah so wait so from my understanding in
Virginia you've read more this than me
basically he was just kind of like
Brandon treated him kind of like a go
boy yeah and like a story he actually
mentions that we kind of always had that
assumption about him
yeah but like
the way that Mark presents it like from
his perspective he he kind of he was
just gullible and didn't really realize
it like didn't realize that he was being
used what he thought he was used to
being used for his vast intellect well
yeah he thought he thought they were
friends yeah that's literally what he
says he was like I thought we were
friends and [__] and he's just like
pretty much using me do you wanna do you
want to get into why he's so [__]
angry yes please uh so somebody asked
can you elaborate on the lying about
money comment
yes he took me off thick boy payroll one
of three sources I was paid from thick
tgh and tfatk reducing my monthly pay by
over a thousand without telling me but
also reprimanded me then later fired me
for in part not showing up to work on
Shob show which is part of thick two
various times promised certain
independent contract pay like happy
hippo ad reads for a thousand dollars a
month and later say oh I meant that was
for you and Chappelle combined so it's
actually five hundred dollars a month he
was telling him he was getting ad reads
and he was splitting them I believe that
here's the thing listen Mark I'll give
you this I believe that these are things
that sound 100 well first off
what a St what a weird exact detail why
would you make that up like that's not a
lie you would make up no he's not
bullshitting I to be honest with you
this I believe 100 believe this no from
Reading This Thread and reading his
answers and how [__] candid he is
look man uh Mark is a [__] all the
things that we've said about him there's
one thing Mark Carly is not and that's a
[__] liar no I don't think he's I
don't think he's been lying about any of
this stuff yeah that's a good point I
believe I'll give you that 110 he is not
he's like doofus but he's not a liar how
much was how much was it he said Callan
was getting paid for uh fighting the kid
a month there's 25 G's I think yeah 25
G's 25 G's a month a month so nice just
to show up in sandals and sit Indian
style I'm sorry crisscross applesauce I
don't want to offend anybody
um
uh good so uh actually 500 a month I
mean I don't even make a thousand
dollars a month from Happy Hippo at read
time also luckily found written proof
that contradicts uh the framing of This
Promise 3K tiger thick pay a month then
later his manager called when I invoiced
it and was like oh yeah that's for you
and Jay who wasn't really doing much at
all wait a second the three kit you were
supposed to get 3K a month which okay
you know you could liveable barely but
livable it where you are you know
whether are there other money you're
making but then just for the that one
pay no no no I know I know I know no no
I know I know I know but but but but
then after saying that then go no no I
meant split it
that sounds like first off you know what
it sounds like and this is why we said
Mark you're not even like the top 10th
worst person out there not even top 10
you don't break this not even yeah
you're not even a [__] top 50 worst
person in L.A no in La so to be fair if
you take anything for kids yeah they're
really bad people I will say this if you
take anything out of this clip know that
yeah I think you're stupid we think
you're kind of dumb idiot but you're
instruct dummy in your
pseudo-intellectual but honestly we
don't hate you but Brennan is a hateable
person you know what I mean oh he's a
piece of [__] and I believe every word
they [__] he's saying and like this
he's a piece of [__] that's a good point
somebody you you you ran in the chat
said looks Marcus mark and that's true I
mean he is what he is but which is fine
so he
he
the pay thing I believe it's almost like
Brendan doesn't know how to run a
[__] company
yeah and he's afraid to ask for help
because one of what cost them money and
two he wouldn't seem like a self-made
man like Rogan
because that's who Brendan wants to be
Brennan Brendan Schaub wants to be Joe
Rogan there's no question about it you
know yeah whoa hold on I just read ahead
also he claimed it was my job to do
security for him on the road but did not
pay me for the roughly 50 hours a week
in minimum where technically I was on
the job I got no extra money for being
on the road but Max how shitty I am at
my security job in his act Mark does my
security but he's always on his phone so
if you want to murder me now's your
chance you know he was always on his
phone except when he needs narcissistic
supply for mothers around him Brendan
he's literally jealous of people's
phones
so that was very funny that's actually
very funny
big gay Redemption Arc you guys think
I'm kidding big gay Redemption are
turning around on this guy big gay
Redemption Arc I don't know man the
honesty in it is kind of endearing like
just that alone it's like man you're
just a silly goofy [__] but like
you're not a bad person
here's what I'm gonna do just to show
Olive Branch here's an olive branch
merch
you've now been upgraded from Big Gay
lion to Big by curious lion there you go
that's an upgrade okay I don't hate it a
BBC L hear me out I think you need to
move to there you go you need and you
need to move to Nashville become a uh an
acolyte of theovan all right get him
hooked on Adderall and steroids
oh he's here here [__] actually
theobrine just gets [__] jacked
jacked and [__] wired yeah all the
time just wired
just just oh yeah
yeah can you get get to the field one
remember because remember that whole
that whole kerfuffle if you will about
the fly the flyer yeah this this is this
is the last one we'll do okay so the
this comment was deleted by the user but
you can you can tell by what it was yeah
what it was at first I believe Brendan
that Theo had really committed to it and
threw him under the bus Brendan was
heated but I was like okay dude if he's
throwing you under the bus publicly then
you gotta say something be like LOL
that's funny Theo you agreed to it we
both know his unwillingness to do that
makes me very skeptical it went down
like he claims not saying Theo is
totally innocent but it's 90 10 80 20
Papa Theo
I used to use it
big gay Redemption Arc Mark big gay
Redemption Arc buddy